les yeux que vous acheter au supermarché
sont souvent pondus par des poules est
en cash
alors bien sûr ça pose des problèmes
d'éthique notamment vis-à-vis de la
souffrance animale mais ce n'est pas de
ça dont je veux parler aujourd'hui tant
chaque cage ou trouve plusieurs poulet
imaginez maintenant que la survie de
votre famille dépendent du nombre deux
ponts du que faire
faut-il aider les poulets les plus
prolifiques à se reproduire là bien sûr
envie de répondre oui puisque ainsi à la
génération suivante il n'y aura que des
poulets qui descendent de poulet
prolifique et ses poulets qui partage le
génome de poulet prolifique seront sans
doute prolifique aux aussi tel semble
être une application immédiate de la
théorie de l'évolution
et pourtant en 1996 le généticien
williams nuire à trouver une meilleure
façon de maximiser le nombre de thons du
lieu de sélectionner les poulets les
plus prolifiques meyer a décidé de
sélectionner les cages les plus
prolifiques
autrement dit muller a fait se
reproduire les poulets dont la cage
était la plus prolifique en termes
évolutionnaire au lieu d'une sélection
individuelle
on parle d'une sélection de groupes et
de façon stupéfiante lumière a montré
que cette sélection de groupes étaient
bien plus efficace pour maximiser le
nombre d'oeufs pondus que la sélection
individuelle et il ya une très bonne
explication à cela
les poulets les plus prolifiques sont en
fait des poulets violents voire
cannibale qui grâce à leur statut
prédominant peuvent pondre en paix ok
maintenant imaginons que les différentes
cage était en fait les différents
continents
sur terre on verrait alors que les
continents qui se peuple le plus
rapidement sont les continents dont les
cages sont les plus prolifiques pas ceux
où un individuel le plus prolifique
imaginez maintenant qu'une guerre où une
épidémie virale fasse disparaître les
populations les moins nombreuses ne
restera alors plus que des descendants
de cash prolifique
c'est la sélection de groupes qui aura
triomphé pas la sélection individuelle
et cette sélection de groupes
elle semble parfaitement pertinente pour
expliquer la sélection artificielle des
poulets cependant pendant longtemps de
nombreux généticiens ont rejeté
l'existence d'une sélection naturelle de
groupes aujourd'hui semblerait que ça
change légèrement mais ce changement est
loin d'être paisible
en fait il ya quelques années j'ai même
eu l'occasion d'assister à une
conférence à montréal à l'interface
entre la théorie des jeux et la biologie
mathématiques ou des biologistes
évolutionnaire pro sélection de groupes
dans cessé de violemment attaqué les
partisans de la sélection de parentèle
quand on a brièvement parlé dans
l'épisode 25 en allant même jusqu'à dire
que les partisans du mauvais camp ne
comprennent rien aux calculs triviaux
qu'ils effectuent et entière des
conclusions biologiques comme si
l'égalité un plus un égale de avait des
conséquences sur la nature humaine
les débats entre biologistes
mathématiques ça peut être très violent
alors loin de moi l'idée de trancher ce
débat houleux
quoique je suis personnellement
partisans du hashtag tous les modèles
sauf au hashtag certains sont utiles et
même si ça donne l'impression que j'ai
juste pas envie de me mouiller j'ai
quand même l'impression que chacun de
ces modèles est utile à sa manière en
particulier j'ai vraiment envie de vous
parler de l'hypothèse défendue par
jonathan wright selon ait certes
nombreux sont les cas où une sélection
de groupes apparente est en fait plus
facilement expliquées par une sélection
de parentèle mais il existe au moins un
cas où la sélection de groupes aura
prédominer sur la sélection de parentèle
c'est le cas de la sélection naturelle
des homo sapiens c'est à dire nous
autres humains après tout la plupart des
tribus humaines ont disparu ne seront
peut-être plus trop content avec nos
champs de monoculture nos vaccins et la
paix entre nos super puissance et
survivre à l'état de nature sur tout
seul c'est super dur à tout moment on
peut être frappé par la famine la
maladie ou la guerre et c'est pour ça
que homo habilis homo erectus et autres
néandertal n'ont pas réussi à survivre
en fait si on en croit la sélection de
groupes et tribus qui ont survécu sont
celles dont les individus ont
suffisamment collaborer pour la survie
du groupe
autrement dit à cause de la sélection
naturelle n'ont survécu que les tribus
dont les individus étaient prêts à
sacrifier au moins en partie leurs
intérêts individuels pour le bien du
groupe
la sélection de groupes a sélectionné
les groupes dont les individus sont
altruistes et comme en particulier les
individus qui ont survécu bas c'est nous
nous descendons tous deux tribus
d'altruiste nous avons en nous un
instinct qui nous pousse à nous
sacrifier pour les nôtres que cet
instinct soit inné ou acquis sauf qu'à
mener les individus à vouloir se
sacrifier pour les leurs ça paraît
difficile selon ait les tribus qui ont
survécu sont celles qui possédaient des
références symbolique qu'elle soit
visuelle musicale écrite qui
interpellait les membres de ces tribus
et créer ainsi
un sentiment d'appartenance à une
communauté et c'est ce sentiment
d'appartenance qui est la clef de
l'altruisme des individus de la tribu
[Musique]
mieux encore pour éveiller un fort
sentiment communautaire le génie de ces
tribus plus de sacraliser ces éléments
symboliques
c'est ainsi qu'un français va sacraliser
la marseillaise le drapeau bleu blanc
rouge et l'histoire des grands hommes de
la patrie de même un bouddhiste va
sacraliser le tibet les statues du
bouddha et les représentants du
bouddhisme comme le dalaï lama ou encore
un supporters du psg va sacraliser le
maillot les chants des supporters et les
grands joueurs du club qui soit neymar
pauleta ou bernard mendy
tiens en parlant de neymar il a cherché
à me contacter sur twitter je passe il
faut que je réponde ainsi prochain à
tort ait ce qui rend les références
sacré si importante
ce n'est pas tant ce qu'ils sont
vraiment lui-même ce qu'il semble
représenter ce qui rend ces éléments
sacrés si fondamentaux c'est leur
capacité à réveiller l'altruisme des
membres d'une tribu et leur désir de se
sacrifier pour le bien de la tribu alors
tout ça ça peut paraître gentil est
innocent mais je vous invite à aller au
bout du raisonnement sur la sélection de
groupes l'a vu encore et encore dans
cette série le gros problème des
sociétés
c'est l'existence de free riders c'est à
dire de membres de la tribu qui ne
travaille pas pour la tribu ils ne font
que servir leurs propres intérêts
personnels or le truc c'est que à cause
des mutations génétiques toute tribu qui
perdure suffisamment longtemps finira
par voir émerger des individus plus
égoïste et moins susceptibles à l'esprit
communautaire
or de tels individus devraient être plus
prolifique que les autres membres de la
tribu
si bien que les descendants de ces
individus sans esprit communautaire
devrait finir par prédominer dans la
tribu mais alors la tribune aura plus
aucun team player ce qui ne lui
laisserait aucune chance de survie y
attribue finirait donc par disparaître
pour survivre les tribus se devait d'en
pêcher les free riders d'émerger et de
conquérir la tribu elle devait réussir à
détecter et convertir ses free riders en
team player plus important c'est
l'équipe d'hier est un footballeur sauf
que convertir tout le monde en team
player
c'est pas dit que ce soit possible
surtout quand les incentives
individuelles sont énormes
faute de mieux pour survivre les tribus
devait avoir un mécanisme de détection
et d'exclusion des freeriders afin de
dénoncer
être et de les excommunier en
particulier les tribus qui ont survécu
se devait d'être exclusive elle devait
distinguer les vrais membres de la tribu
des potentiels free riders et elle
devait défendre les membres contre les
autres lemieux qui respectent pas le
maillot faut sortir de l'équipe
les tribus qui ont survécu sont celles
dont les membres ont un esprit
communautaire non seulement dans le sens
où ses membres de la tribu sont capables
de se sacrifier pour la tribu mais aussi
dans le sens où ils sont capables de
s'attaquer à ceux qui sont identifiés
comme n'appartenant pas à la tribu et
les individus qui ont survécu nous nous
descendons de ceux qui sont prêts à se
sacrifier pour le groupe quitte à
attaquer ceux qui sont à l'extérieur du
groupe
la sélection de groupes n'a pas
sélectionné les purs altruiste envers
toute autre elle a sélectionné
l'hooliganisme politique
cette capacité que l'on a à défendre
irrationnellement les groupes auxquels
on s'identifie à constamment éternue et
les symboles de nos groupes et à
s'attaquer à ce qui semble mettre nos
groupes en danger il s'agit là d'une
observation récurrente des sciences
cognitives
on a un comportement très différent
envers ceux que l'on considère comme
différent ou pas comme nous autres par
opposition aux comportements que l'on
adopte envers ceux qui appartiennent au
même groupe que nous je vous renvoie
encore une fois vers l'excellent livre
de jonathan wright où il présente
plusieurs expériences de psychologie qui
montre cela on retrouve d'ailleurs cette
méfiance voire cette haine envers les
individus extérieurs au groupe dans
quasiment tous les groupes sociaux
prédominant beaucoup de non croyants
vous typiquement chercher à stigmatiser
les croyants et a tourné en ridicule
leurs éléments sacrés et à l inverse les
croyants par souvent des non croyants
avec des termes péjoratifs comme le mot
payen les supporters du psg comme
beaucoup d'autres groupes de supporters
aiment stigmatiser voire insulter les
éléments sacrés des équipes ennemies
les scientifiques vont s'attaquer plus
violemment encore à ceux qui se font
passer pour des scientifiques mais ne
correspondent pas aux standards de la
communauté scientifique
cette distinction entre nous et eux est
souvent indispensable à la survie du
groupe
la survie de nos groupes dépend de notre
oligan isme politique et ça on le
retrouve en politique aussi
on peut même résumé une grosse partie
des débats classique de politique à une
pour éveiller l'esprit communautaire des
citoyens et faire surgir l'oligarque
politique qui sommeille en eux
bien souvent le meilleur moyen d'activer
cette hooliganisme politique c'est de
stigmatiser le clan opposé notre moral
instinctive cette morale qui a été
sélectionné par la sélection de groupes
nous pousse à choisir un camp et à le
défendre bec et ongles en rejetant toute
alternative en usant de condescendance
de culpabilisation de moqueries poire de
violence notre moral de hooligans
polarise nous opinions politiques
et bien sûr tout ça est ensuite accentué
par les propriétés de nos scrutins la
ségrégation idéologique et la viralité
des convictions idéologiques deux
sortent toujours mieux diviser les
groupes sociaux identifiés par des
symboles sacrés les capitalistes contre
les communistes elle liberté contre
l'égalité l'ordre social contre le
progrès social
les boues aristocrate contre la mauvaise
populace les méchants riches contre les
ponts innocent je vous invite à y
réfléchir
quand vous affirmez votre appartenance à
un groupe que ce soit celui des bobos
des scientifiques ou des français
n'exacerbe avez-vous pas par là même
l'exclusion de ceux qui n'appartiennent
pas au groupe ne cherchez-vous pas aussi
à activer l'hooliganisme politique des
vôtres
[Musique]
non
le haut
[Musique]
91 me demande aussi les fictions ne
serait pas du coup des règles du jeu oui
carrément fait et des règles du jeu sont
souvent des fictions n'y a pas de règles
fondamentales du football du basket je
sais trop quel sport les règles ont
toutes été inventé pour que le jeu
devienne intéressant
du coup les règles en tant que tels sont
une fiction fiction qui est partagée qui
sont écrites dans des documents qui lui
permettent d'être plus acceptée par plus
de monde mais c'est l'acceptation de
cette fiction par un grand nombre dans
ce cas selon harari qui fait que ces
fictions créer des nouveaux initiatives
qui peuvent ensuite permettre le
développement de grandes civilisations
entertaining monkeys et fabrice me
demande si par rapport aux insectes
notamment les humains sont si novateur
que ça elle quel est le rôle vraiment
des fictions sachant que les insectes
arrive à coopérer un très très grand
nombre sans avoir à priori de fiction
qui les lie particulièrement alors
l'argument d'art harry c'est que les
insectes en effet arrive à faire de très
grande coopération
mais cette coopération elle est guidée
par l'hygiène et j'ai n'évolue pas très
rapidement du coup elle est moins
capable de s'adapter à un environnement
qui est serait très changeant si on
regarde l'histoire de l'humanité par
rapport à l'histoire révolutionnaire des
fourmis et qui sont depuis le vrai dire
des bêtises mais des millions et des
millions d'années sans des centaines de
millions nous autres humains et là sur
terre depuis seulement cent mille ans et
l'environnement économico social dans
lequel on vit et a été bouleversée au
cours des derniers millénaires et il y
compris au cours des dernières décennies
donc pour que la coopération humaine
puisse perdurer et rester efficace dans
un environnement aussi changeant il est
celle que l'encodage génétique par
exemple de l'empathie ou du mimétisme
est largement insuffisant et pour
pouvoir s'adapter il faut un truc qui
nous permet de nous adapter beaucoup
plus rapidement et selon harris ce truc
ce sont les fictions et une cote à 1 et
pitbull il faut remarquer que
aujourd'hui finalement dans le monde
moderne il ya des espèces de religions
qui sont pas forcément les mêmes que les
religions monothéistes est grandement
régionalistes du passé
par exemple il y en a qui adore apple
attaqué jure que par linux généralement
tous les différents pays où toutes les
différences idéologiques l'on peut avoir
ce sont des fictions qui m'unissent
certains groupes d'individus ensemble
qui leur permettent de collaborer de
d'être plus proches de certains autres
personnes et de certains réseaux de
coopération pea normes mais gilles et jo
jo n 64 ont remarqué que les choses dont
j'ai parlé dans l'épisode précédent
aussi dans l'épisode 7 finalement ça
correspond à la théorie y ait des mêmes
de richard dawkins et on a fait ça
correspond à ce qu'on appelle la
mémétique qui correspond à dire qu'il ya
d'autres choses qui subissent les un peu
les lois de la sélection naturelle et de
la théorie d'évolution avec des
mutations et tout ça à titre personnel
je trouve ça un peu bizarre de donner un
nouveau nom à tout ça on peut juste
appeler ça des éléments culturels ou des
idéologies ou tout ce que vous voulez il
faut juste se rend compte que ça ça a
subi aussi l'évolution
il ya des formes de mutation et de
sélection qui font qu' il ya des trucs
qui restent et ceux qui restent sont les
trucs qui sont aptes à rester qui sont
plus qu'atteint se reproduire et à
survivre dans l'environnement dans
lequel on vit aujourd'hui 2 go rock nous
pose la question de l'existence de
conscience de soi
est-ce que ça s'explique en termes
émotionnel ou est-ce qu'on pourrait tout
simplement agir comme des fourmis
j'ai quand même l'impression que pour
que ces fictions ou notamment louis
ganis mans nous puisse surgir d'avoir
une certaine conscience de soi de soi
dans le groupe puisse être quelque chose
d'utile pour avoir plus de wigan isme
politique donc c'est possible que
conscience de soi pour ces raisons-là a
été sectionné
par la section des ventes au cours de la
même façon il est très possible que les
sociétés dans lesquelles il y avait une
notion de libre arbitre notamment à une
époque où l'économie a commencé à se
libéraliser ou en gros la stratégie
optimale pour une société n'était plus
une ordre hiérarchique très figé mais
quelque chose qui ressemble plus à la
théorie de dernis miss chacun se
spécialise dans un travail et comprend
joue son travail mais façon un peu
étranger presque magique
les spécialisations individuel
conduisent quand même à une production
globale économique assez impressionnante
à partir du moment où on a basculé dans
ce mode de société peut imaginer que les
sociétés dans laquelle la fiction du
libre arbitre était prédominante sont
les sociétés qui se sont le mieux
développer économiquement et du coup
c'est ce qu'on sait le connaît
aujourd'hui
hamster jovial nous demande aussi à
paris je laisserais mon vélo comme je la
za à lausanne non pas du tout et tout
simplement parce que le capital moral
pour utiliser les termes des jeunes en
ait à paris est plus faible qui ne l'est
à lausanne
en tout cas quand il s'agit de ne pas
voler les vélos qui sont dans la rue et
enfin usaï 59 159 me fait remarquer que
de nos jours
l'argent est encore plus fautif que
jamais puisqu'il s'agit juste
d'écritures comptables dans des fichiers
informatiques
et c'est encore plus le cas si on pense
à un truc comme le bitcoin puisque c'est
gérer contrôler par personne c'est juste
une fiction commune et c'est surtout le
fait que beaucoup de gens croient en le
bitcoin sont prêts à utiliser au beacon
qui fondent du bitcoin une fiction utile
pour pouvoir faire des transferts
monétaires notamment et rendre service
et payer les services des uns et des
autres je recommande d'ailleurs vivement
à ce sujet les vidéos d'oreca comprendre
notamment que l'argent finalement c'est
de la dette finalement ce qu'ils ont
fait à être capable de savoir combien
chacun doit un autre et pour cela une
façon de faire c'est écrire tout ça dans
un fichier informatique
et c'est sur ce principe que fonctionne
le bitcoin et j'espère qu'ils avaient
aimé cet épisode j'espère que vous ferez
un petit peu plus attention à
l'hooliganisme non seulement ou autres
organismes des autres notamment
quelqu'un qui commence à être william
politique souvent de ne pas mettre de
l'huile sur le feu en particulier ce sur
quoi je voulais vraiment insisté
aujourd'hui c'est le fait que notre
moral notre moral que l'on a
intuitivement
activement celle qui a été sélectionné
par la sélection naturelle c'est loin
d'être une bonne morale parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de défauts associé à notre
moral intuitive et du coup il va falloir
penser à une morale qui serait vraiment
bonne et c'est ce qu'on va faire la
prochaine fois avec monsieur fillon ou
parlant d'utilitarisme vous avez aimé
cet épisode français le l'ikea le
commentaire est le partage et pensez à
vous abonner pour commenter futurs
épisodes merci aussi peur pour leurs
dons et j'espère que vous serez là la
prochaine fois admiré mon art de
travestir les faiblesses en vérité
j'attends peu de la vie c'est par
humilité je ne cherche pas à me venger
quand on offense c'est qu'il faut savoir
pardonner je suis tout affrontement
c'est parce que la violence ne résout
rien voilà comment je drap mon
impuissance d'héroïsme joe klein li ning
d'ayew naïve face